un soir rama nouveau reçus chez lui
présenta h un drame à la nobis un
collègue alors étudiant à cambridge mal
à nos pays se pose le problème suivant
imaginez une rue avec des maisons
numérotés dans l'ordre avec les anti
naturel
on suppose que la rue contient entre 50
et 500 maisons et qu'il existe une
maison tels que la somme des numéros à
gauche de la maison est égale à la somme
des numéros à droite
combien y at-il de maisons quand ma la
novice avait fini de poser le problème
ramanujan redonna immédiatement une
formule magique qui listait toutes les
solutions du problème lorsque l'on
oublie la contrainte selon laquelle il
ya entre 50 et 500 maisons
n'hésitez pas à mettre pause et à
essayer de résoudre ce problème par vous
même vous avez 5 secondes pour mettre
pose pas pour toujours
comme vous l'imaginez mann vice tombe
pas des nues et s'empressa de demander à
ramen gens comment ils avaient su
résoudre ce problème aussi rapidement
amman - répondit qu'il sentait que la
solution pouvait s'écrire comme une
fraction continue et il ne restait plus
qu'à déterminer laquelle ça paraît
simple ans les modes
sauf que si rama nous on n'a mis que
quelques secondes pour inventer sa
solution du problème
il va me falloir dix minutes pour la
décrire et encore je ne fais que la
décrire pour l'approuver vraiment il
faudrait des dizaines et des dizaines de
pages de maths de très haut vol
avant de commencer parlons d'un autre
génie le grand gars plutôt le petit
gosse quand il avait 8 ans son prof de
maths qui en avaient marre du droit de
sa classe demanda à tous de calculer la
somme des 100 premiers nombres
selon la légende de quelques secondes
plus tard gosses rendit son ardoise avec
un seul nombre qui était la réponse du
problème et aucun calcul intermédiaires
et bien sûr c'est qu'à la bonne réponse
excuse de gosses était d'ajouter à la
somme des 100 premiers nombres dans
l'ordre croissant
la somme des 100 premiers nombres dans
l'ordre décroissant en ajoutant terme à
terme go se rendit compte que le
résultat était une somme de son ombre
tous égaux à 101 et ça c'est sans
poisson qui fait dix mille cent sauf que
10100 c'est deux fois la sienne dès son
premier membre du coup la somme de 100
premiers nombres et la moitié de 2100
soit 5050 plus généralement la somme des
haines premier nombre et en poids et en
plus un
le tout divisé par deux revenons-en aux
maisons numérotées de rama les gens on
va appeler n le nombre de maisons et
aime le numéro de la maison de ramanujan
dire que la somme de numéros à gauche
est égale à celle des numéros à droite
ça revient à dire que la somme des
numéros à gauche et la moitié de la
somme de tous les numéros - le numéro de
la maison d'art amadou gens en utilisant
le théorème du petit gosse on en vient à
l'égalité est moins 1 fois m / 2 est
égale à la moitié de haine fois n + 1 /
2 - m et après quelques manipulations et
j'ai pris qu'on peut réécrire tout cela
en deux n + 1 / m
au carré est égal à 8 + 1 / m²
je n'ai pas suivi toutes les étapes de
cailloux ce n'est vraiment pas grave
hein choyé très très vite parce qu'il ya
pas grand chose d'intéressant dans ses
calculs
non la difficulté et le génie de rama
yade ou jean c'est d'avoir su résoudre
cette équation en un coup d'oeil et
surtout c'est la manière dont il s'y est
pris la première astuce incroyable de
ramon gens c'est de remarquer que la
fraction deuxième puce 1 / elle est un
rationnel mais à l'infini quand mdm sont
très très grand elle doit tendre vers
une valeur très précise à savoir la
racine carrée de 8 parce que 1 / m² va
devenir très petit du coup à l'infini on
à l'approximation 2 n + 1 / n à peu près
égale à racine carrée de 8
ok mais ça a priori ça sert à rien saisi
d'une bonne approximation de la fraction
deuxième puissant / ame
quand est née m sont des très grandes
solution du problème mais ça ne nous dit
absolument rien sur les vraies valeurs
de haine et n dans le cac finit à priori
l'utilisation de l'infini par amadou
gens nous éloigne du vrai problème à
résoudre
a priori et la viande astuces de la mort
qui tue ramanou vent se met à écrire
racine carrée de 8 comme une fraction
continu c'est-à-dire un nombre plus une
fraction dont le dénominateur est un
nombre plus une fraction dont le
dénominateur est un non plus une
fraction de temps modernes une
interaction plus une fraction non plus
présenté à la limite on a une égalité
entre racine carrée de 8 et l'infraction
continue la beauté de cette égalité
c'est que si on a la flemme de faire la
fraction continue jusqu'à l'infini
alors on obtient une approximation
absolument remarquable de racine carrée
de 8 par un nombre rationnelle il reste
toutefois une difficulté il ya plusieurs
fractions continue qui sont capables de
décret racine carrée de 8
laquelle choisir et bien pour choisir la
bonne fraction continue on peut
s'inspirer des petites solution du
problème la solution la plus simple en
fait je ne sais pas si vous y avez pensé
c'est le cas où est né des galas ou
quelqu'un à la maison de ramène aux gens
et m égal 1
en effet la somme des numéros à gauche
et alors 0 est la somme des numéros à
droite et 0,6 et oui parce que ajouté
rien du tout fait zéro un peu comme
multiplier rien du tout fait 1
or si n est égal à 1 et m est égal à 1
2 n + 1 / n est égal à 3 du kurram à
nogent va chercher une fraction continue
dont la première approximation est égal
à 3 hélas sa connaissance intime des
fractions continue a dû lui souffler la
bonne réponse
il choisit la fraction continue racine
carrée de 8 est égal à 3 - 1 / 6 / 6 / 6
maintenant 10 et partis politiques
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire maintenant
avec cette fraction continue ils rament
à nogent choisi d'en étudier les
approximations successives la première
on l'a vu ces trois là deuxième ces
trois mois un sixième qui est égale à 17
6e puis on a 3 - 1 / 6 - 1 / 6 qui est
égal à 99 35e puis trois mois 1 / 6 - 1
/ 6 - 1 6e qui est égal à 577 204e et
ainsi de suite
mais que faire de ces approximations
successives et bien ces fractions
successives représente 2 n + 1 / m du
coup le dénominateur devra être quelque
chose comme m
le numérateur quelque chose comme 2 n +
en particulier on peut lire la valeur de
m lisant le dénominateur et on peut
retrouver la valeur de haine en faisant
le numérateur - 1 / 2 et ceci nous donne
les valeurs de ntm qui sont 1 1 8 6 car
9,35 288 204 et ainsi de suite
tiens mais cette dernière solution c'est
pas celle qu'il nous faudrait par hasard
on a bien un nombre de maisons haine qui
est entre 50 et 500 et si on regarde la
somme des numéros à gauche n'obtient ème
fois elle - 1 / 2 qui est égal à 20 1706
alors que si on regarde la somme de
toutes les maisons - la maison
m on obtient 40 termine 412 qui vient le
double du résultat précédent
incroyable la méthode mystérieuse de ram
à nogent nous a servi sur un plateau la
solution du problème
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
de ce qui s'est passé là c'est
complètement monstrueusement incroyable
pour résoudre ce problème qui est
parfaitement fini plutôt que de chercher
à bien le comprendre
amano jean est parti dans l'infini et
dans effraction continue il ya donc
étudié des cas qui existent pas qu'ils
sont pas des cas qui correspond à quoi
que ce soit de fini
il a fini par en déduire toutes les
solutions du problème est le plus
incroyable c'est que ça marche et le
fait que ça marche
skype super troublant alors bien sûr je
n'ai pas prouvé que ça marche tout ce
que j'ai fait dans cette vidéo
si j'ai pris une des valeurs prédite par
un jour et j'ai vérifié qu'elle était
effectivement solution du problème
si vous voulez un peu plus loin vous
pouvez essayer plus de valeur et vous
constaterez que toutes les valeurs que
vous testerez sont effectivement des
solution du problème et ça c'est
carrément l'attitude des mathématiciens
qui avaient affaire à rames à nogent il
constatait que les équations qu'il
donnait était juste les mathématiciens
de l'époque ne comprenait pas pourquoi
l'intuition de ramanujan n'avait rien à
voir avec leur façon de penser
cette intuition de ramon jour elle est
déroutante et elle vaut vraiment de l'or
la lymphe en a parlé de la somme des
entier le fait que cette somme était
égal hommes - un 12e et âmes 71 r1 ainsi
que bastos font la remarque que l'on
peut réécrire la somme des entiers comme
une somme de 1 au final or la somme d 1
est égal à -1 2 me pourquoi est ce que
la somme identique se régale à bourg
saint jean vient le problème dans les
raisonnements de xam 74 r1 et bastos
c'est le fait que les sommes infinie
divergentes son nom associative ça veut
dire qu'on n'a pas le droit de mettre
des parenthèses on est obligé d'ajouter
la somme terme par terne dans le bonheur
toda rocks pierre lacombe et yoav
albrecht sont un petit peu intrigué par
l'effet casimir n'y crois pas trop on
trouve ça bizarre que nerfs qui est
négative
il faut savoir que les calculs que j'ai
fait on peut les faire complètement
différemment pour essayer de contourner
voire un peu plus l'utilisation de la
somme des antilles est égal à moins
12e c'est ce qu'a fait notamment science
étonnante dans son super billet de blog
sur l'effet casimir parce qu'en fait ce
qui compte vraiment ce qu'ils aient un
effet prédictive c'est pas là l'énergie
parce qu'on peut pas mesurer l'énergie
en tant que tel on peut mesurer que des
variations d'énergie et cette variation
d'énergie en fait elle s'exprime en tant
que force
c'est ce que j'ai fait quand j'ai
calculé la variation de l'énergie en
fonction de la distance fixe entre les
plaques et du coup on peut imaginer
qu'il ya deux plaques
le fait qu'elles soient séparées d'une
distance x fait qu'à une certaine
énergie qui associé au vide entre les
deux qui va être négatif mais si on
rapproche les plaques l'énergie va être
encore punissent négative dont puisqu'en
leurs voisins sur x du coup les plaques
peuvent rentrer dans un état d'énergie
moindres en se rapprochant et ça ça
correspond à dire qu'il ya une force qui
rapproche les deux plaques le calcul de
cette force
quelques des variations de l'énergie
peut se faire en court-circuitant
l'égalité sommes des anciens il ya le
moins 1 12e même si au final ça
correspond vraiment à essayer d'enlever
le terme divergent quant on fait le
développement limité
alex gérardin demande pourquoi est ce
que le fait que 0 à gerland est
acquiesce beauté mathématique est ce
qu'on ne pouvait pas le prouver
un jour alors pour vraiment répondre à
la question avec son jardin il faudrait
rentrer dans des formalismes on dit un
appel axiomatique pour savoir vraiment
de quoi on parle par 2-0 2-1 et du
sénégal tout cela c'est vraiment pas
très bien passé et on finira pas en
parler dans cette série sur l'infini ce
que je peux dire c'est que dans toutes
les théories classiques des
mathématiques 0 est différent de 1 donc
si on arrive à prouver que 0 était
gallard et que 0 est différent de 1
on a une vraie contradiction on a
quelque chose qui est forcément faux et
le fait qu'on ait quelque chose qu'il
faut c'est implique qu'on peut prouver
tout et n'importe quoi parce que c'est
un petit peu bizarre mais on logique
la phrase si la france était championne
d'europe alors les poules auront des
dents est une phrase qui est
parfaitement vrai parce qu'on sait que
le prémice ce qui est juste après le 6
est faux et le fait que ce qui après le
seae fausse implique que la phrase en
tant que telle est vrai indépendamment
de ce qui vient après le alors c'est
assez perturbant et déroutant mais c'est
un truc qui est incroyablement fécond et
qui a permis de prouver de beaucoup de
choses en mathématiques surtout les
alternatives est très insatisfaisante
bref du coût 6 0 est égal à 1 eh ben on
peut tout prouver tout est vrai tout est
faux tout n'a rien ni queue ni tête
c'est pas très bon vous tombez lui très
perturbée parce qu'au final donne
l'impression que j'ai pas vraiment donné
de réponse à la question est ce que
l'égalité sommes des antilles - un
douzième est vrai nom est est ce que
c'est vraiment c'est une question
difficile c'est une question très
intéressante aussi c'est pour ça que
cette égalité est aussi intrigante est
aussi passionnante
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ça voter c'est
parce que c'est pas si clairement fausse
n est pas si clairement vrai c'est une
question assez ouverte
et en plus ça dépend du formalisme dans
lequel on se place et ça on en parlera
beaucoup bien sûr dans les épisodes à
venir dans cette série sur un fil enfin
eric hattan ça fait remarquer que le
fait que la somme des entiers également
un douzième permet de prédire l'effet
casimir et du coup quelque chose qui est
vrai ne prouve pas que l'égalité sommes
des antillais 312e est vrai pour
commencer et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec cela mais ce que je trouve
très intéressant avec cette remarque
c'est qu'en fait c'est que leur procès
qui a été fait à de nombreux concepts
dans l'histoire des mathématiques comme
par exemple les nombreux imaginaire
imaginaire permettait de résoudre des
équations et ç'a donné la bonne réponse
la fin mais au milieu il y avait un truc
bizarre qui était louée originaire du
coup ce que c'est vrai quand même est-ce
que le nom imaginaire les vrais c'était
une question difficile
et dans le cas des noms imaginaire
napout fini par prouver que c'est dans
l'imaginaire et est vrai qu'ils
existaient en un certain sens il eu un
problème similaire mais avec une
conclusion assez différente en tout cas
beaucoup plus compliqué concernant les
infinitésimaux de l'église l'église
grâce aux infinitésimaux a pu calculer
plein de trucs des trajectoires des
pommes et des planètes et tout ça
m'aidait infinitésimaux de l'église
semblait ne pas exister et il a été
vivement critiquée et lui-même l'abysse
ne croyait pas vraiment à l'existence de
ces infinitésimaux donc je pense qu'on
est dans un cas assez similaires et on
va explorer cette analogie dans
l'épisode sûr puisqu'on va parler
justement de l'histoire de ces infiniti
et j'espère que vous avez aimé cet
épisode la prochaine fois parler des
offres mixmo donc ya pas mal d'autres
choses assez folle à savoir sur un
habitat voir des vidéos de singh manhas
et remet en selle sur la sommation de
ram à nous vendre la troisième bonne
raison que j'avais donnés en vidéo
précédent pour laquelle la seule entité
galles - 1 12e je vous conseille aussi
une vidéo de ma femme au coeur sur les
fractions tienne qui est vraiment un
truc vraiment passionnant et de tout ça
presque dommage qu'on
mais jamais enseigné ces fractions en
continu ricol nous allons au final la
bonne façon de représenter pire sur
devait communiquer la valeur de pillage
mais même si on voulait communiquer les
décimales de pied dont aucun sens mieux
essayer de renvoyer les entiers de la
décomposition fraction cantine de
simples d'une copie et ça pour en savoir
plus lire et cette vidéo amateur
longueur mais je voudrais aussi le
billet de blog de sciences étonnante sur
les poissons plus petits brise
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
la ligue et à la commenter la partager
pense à vous abonner aux épisodes merci
auditeurs pourront et j'espère que vous
ferez la prochaine fois ils veulent
ramener le régime des ciseaux pcij 2006
à gauthier approximativement de rigolade
james
quoi